the lengths actors will go to just to
fit a specific role perfectly
are unimaginable especially when it
comes to changing their physical bodies
these a-listers endure months of intense
training and strict diet plans in order
to drastically change how they look for
just a few short months
the celebs we'll be discussing in
today's video are just a few of the most
mind-boggling weight gain
transformations that have happened in
hollywood
what's up guys welcome to gym time
battle of the sexes wasn't the only
battle emma participated in while
portraying her character king
for the role she had to gain 15 pounds
of muscle weight
in just three months before making her
way on set that means she had to get
herself on a strict training routine
that involved weightlifting
and 300 pound hip thrusts she also had
to introduce two
very high calorie protein shakes to her
diet every day
by the time she stepped onto the set she
was lifting 185 pounds with no problems
her trainer jason walsh said she took it
seriously and
wanted to do the story justice and then
after three weeks when you're like i can
lift this josh hutcherson was just 15
pounds shy from being the hunger games
filmmaker's perfect peta malarke
josh being the dedicated actor he is
went on a high protein
low carb diet and hit the gym for some
weight training with an ex-navy trainer
while a lot of people may have been
bothered by the lifestyle change
josh was nothing but happy about it it
was cool to go through that sort of
physical transformation
zac efron has always been pretty fit but
his role on baywatch required him to put
on muscle weight
like we've never seen him do before long
gone are his basketball and troy bolton
days
he was put on a super strict organic
diet that even told him which hours of
the day he was allowed to eat
what as for exercise he mainly practiced
heavy lifting and stabilization
exercises
but zack wants to make sure that
everyone knows his body in baywatch
was super unrealistic for guys that's
unrealistic i'm telling you
i got very big and buff for that movie
but i don't want people to think that's
the best way to be
like be your size i don't want to
glamorize this
jlaw was more than happy to gain some
weight for her role as tiffany in silver
lining's playbook
and when asked by the director she said
she'd get on it right away
while she managed to succeed in the end
all the dancing required by her
character made it a huge challenge
eventually she had to slow down the
dancing and focus more on consuming
extra calories
i was like i could get a salad and he
said well if you can get a salad get a
salad and i said i'm getting a billy
cheese steak
your favorite sheriff was not allowed to
lose his dad bod for stranger things
david harbour got into serious shape
when he starred in his hellboy film
but once it was time to return to the
stranger things set as jim hopper
the creators needed him to pack on the
pounds and
david thought that there was no better
way to do that than by eating
plenty of donuts i know i shouldn't give
away season 3 spoilers but fret not good
hopper fans
you shall have your dad bod for season
three
i'm just gonna be out here by myself
eating all this candy
i'm gonna get fat kj oppa made a huge
commitment when he joined the riverdale
cast as archie
archie is arguably the fittest and most
active character which means kj
appa hasn't once stopped training to be
able to keep up with the script
to initially gain muscle weight and stay
in shape kj
forced on intense strength training and
ab workouts every single day
apparently the training aspect is pretty
brutal especially because he's expected
to be at his best almost 365 days a year
try the workout it's gnarly it's a hard
one
while chris pratt was filming his comedy
series parks and recreation
he would always joke about gaining
weight and putting on his dad bod until
the showrunners actually asked him to do
just that
he gained over 40 pounds while filming
and said there was an ongoing set joke
where they would bet on how much he
could eat to gain weight
however this made his transformation
into star-lord and guardians of the
galaxy
a little more difficult all right let's
give the sucker a test drive
the umbrella academy showrunners wanted
to make sure that tom hopper got as
close as possible to luther's half
gorilla body
that meant tom had to gain 20 pounds of
muscle before they added on the
prosthetics to top him off
what makes this so impressive is that
tom did it all himself
from the research to the actual diet
changes and workout plan
he added in intense weight training and
completely cut out any junk from his
lifestyle
i like to make it as unconventional as
possible
believe it or not chris evans wasn't
always the bulky captain america we know
although he wasn't as small as steve
rogers was he was very lean
this meant he had to majorly bulk up for
his role in the mcu
like many others he did it through
changing his diet and exercise plan
it's a very balanced workout hitting
every single muscle
i think even my toes got bigger he
described working out his muscles as
destroying them
and even took some difficult gymnastics
classes
chris evans wasn't the only chris or mcu
actor who had to bulk up with muscle
weight
his co-star chris hemsworth went through
a similar process when preparing for
thor
he is the god of thunder after all he
worked closely with the trainer to get
that perfect
god-like body with exercises like
flipping ginormous
tires muscle training also became a part
of his daily routine and he never missed
a day
even when on vacation with his family
sam hewitt knew right off the bat he
wasn't gonna get the rugged jaime fraser
body with the martial arts training he
had been doing previous to outlander
when asked about what his motivation was
for this training sam said he's
an outdoorsman a fighter and i wanted to
build that sort of body
so in order to gain the weight he stuck
to strictly heavy lifting
we're gonna say he understood the
assignment and got an a
we're used to seeing bryce howard saving
the day and doing very intense stunt
work in jurassic world
but before that the training for her
role in black mirror required her to
gain a total of 30 pounds
bryce said the only way to do this was
to constantly be eating
i ate around the clock first thing in
the morning last thing before i closed
my eyes i'd have food by my bed i'd get
up in the middle of the night and have a
chocolate bar
she credits crossfit for getting her
back into shape for other roles like
jurassic world
the bold part is not the gaining taylor
lautner almost completely lost the role
of jacob black in twilight because he
wasn't big enough
however he proved the filmmakers wrong
and changed his entire lifestyle in
order to gain the 30 pounds of muscle
weight needed to look like a werewolf
he completely cut junk food from his
diet and worked out at the gym
five days a week henry cavill was asked
by the showrunners to
transform his body for his role in the
witcher he delved into the world of
bodybuilding and
actually followed the regime of some of
the most successful professionals in the
field
the exercises mostly focused on core and
strength training however he also
admitted he needed to psychologically
change as well
although he got the work done he still
dehydrated himself during certain
shirtless scenes in order to look as
defined as possible
her majesty will do as she wishes
charlize theron wanted to feel what her
character marlowe was going through in
her film tully
and made the huge commitment of gaining
50 pounds for the role
while things were fun in the beginning
because she got to eat with no
restriction
she said i got hit pretty hard with
depression
afterwards it took her over a year to
get back to her pre-telly self
both physically and mentally you don't
expect it and then all of a sudden i was
like wow i
am really struggling with this it was
hard whether it was muscle weight or not
these actors endured hardships just to
meet the big hollywood studio
expectations
it's even wilder to think about how some
of these actors went directly into
transforming their bodies for another
movie
after this which transformation do you
think was the most drastic
thanks for watching